[Music]
so chuck i got an explainer but it's
like a sports explainer uh-oh so we
called in gary because the two of you
were my co-hosts for star talk sports
edition
okay yeah
can we do that is there a rule against
that are you trying to tell me we're
going to stop the other ones because uh
what's happening what's going on
okay
so we're like mid-season of baseball
right now and i just thought we should
have a little chat
about what people call a rising fastball
rising fast very hard to hit
very hard to hit because you see the
ball coming in
and you're ready to swing for it and you
always swing underneath it
and
because you think it's going to be
somewhere where it isn't of course
that's the whole point of what the
pitcher is trying to do the whole point
is to fool the batter in whatever way
they can but i just wanted to focus in
this particular moment on the rising
fastball so the batter describes the
ball as
rising
rising up from whatever wherever they
saw they thought it was going to be
and but of course gravity doesn't work
that way
unless unless the pitcher is a jedi
gravity doesn't work that way and
old-timers among us
old-timer americans so gary might not
know this back in the 1970s they lowered
the height of the pitcher's mound
to give a better advantage to the
batters right i forgot how much was it
just a few inches
and
when you just get shorter pictures
that would be the same effect
[Laughter]
so gary you want short pictures but
they're not easy to come by right uh you
know they they
some of the most dominating pitchers
have all been tall randy johnson randy
johnson among them yeah it was a giant
imagine you think about the length of
lever that they're able to bring to a
pitch
and then you've got the vertical aspect
and him stood on a mound even if you
lowered it yes
he showed up for practice they were like
you in the wrong sport man
you're in the wrong spot
the basketball court's that way
then they finally couldn't jump so okay
you stay right
do you remember seeing that video of him
pitching and he completely vaporized a
pigeon that flew across the past yes i
saw that a pigeon flew across and there
was nothing left of the pigeon
that's that's
now that was i mean if you had to die
you know a randy johnson festival
completely obliterating what are the
chances of that actually
happening
whatever those chances are he made it
happen it happened
that pigeon is more famous than the
sully captain sully sullenberger
geese that's for sure right right right
yeah there's basically no birds are not
sturdy objects right they have to be
light enough to fly their bones are very
fragile the bones are basically hollow
hollow they're possible to be hollow
yeah yeah yeah otherwise they'd be um so
if you take the energy of a randy
johnson fastball and ask what happens
when you deposit that much energy into a
pigeon there's basically no pigeon left
and so you have a you have a feathered
pillow that's that's that's right
that's some feathers for a pillow that's
it that's awesome so getting back to the
rising fastball so uh
so here's the point uh so in the 1970s
they lowered the mound i think was the
70s yep they lowered the mound
to bring some advantage back to the
batter
so that the pitcher is not towering over
you plus with their fully outstretched
arm and they're pitching sort of down to
you all right rather than straight at
you all right so that helped a little
bit but like you said gary you know a
shorter pitcher would have had the same
effect as lowering the mound so
um so what it did is it put shorter
pictures at a disadvantage okay um
relative to taller pictures where they
didn't make a difference so
make a long story short as you know you
can put a spin on a ball
and as long as the ball is thrown
through an atmosphere
such as what we have on earth
then the arc of the ball
will veer from what would be normal to
the force of gravity from what forcibly
from what you'd expect
giving purely the force of gravity
acting on the object which is why you
cannot have curveballs on the moon
it will not work
okay you cannot have rising fastballs on
the moon it will not work all of these
trajectory adjustments that are
happening on route between the pitcher's
release point and the catch and the
batter
which is a little less than 60 feet
right um uh because the pitcher's arm is
forward of the pitching rubber and it's
the pitching rubber that's 60 feet six
inches from home plate so
it's really you're talking about 58 feet
something however wherever their arm is
at the point of release
so and then of course the batter only
has a fraction of a second to decide so
a lot of the batter's decision
has to
be
um i don't want to call it intuitive but
it has to be what their
native understanding of gravity is going
to be or their understanding of the
picture some combination of the two okay
so if you spin the ball
with a backspin so the top of the ball
is spinning back towards you okay we'll
call that a backspin yeah because for
every backspin there's a part of the
ball that's moving forward okay so you
have to be you have to specify what the
top of the ball is doing so if you throw
the ball where the top of the ball has
backspin
that will create a difference in air
pressure between the bottom and the top
of the ball
so because the air moving across the top
of the bot has different speeds relative
to the surface of the ball
so it speeds up slows down speeds up
slow down
uh rotating well no but but it is
rotating but only one side of the ball
will feel the same constant extra force
okay either constant more force or a
constant less force all right so i'm
part of the ball i'm going over the top
i'm moving
i'm so
how should we say this so the top of the
ball
is
is spinning back towards the pitcher
okay
and the and the air is moving in that
same direction across the top of the
ball
so that so the relative speed between
this top surface of the ball
and the air moving across it
the difference between them is less
than the bottom of the ball that's
moving towards the batter
okay the bottom wall is moving towards
the batter and the air is coming back
across so in one case you add the spin
speed to the ball speed in the other
case you subtract it and that difference
creates a pressure difference between
the top and the bottom if you do that
side to side it'll move the ball left to
right
yeah pure and simple we use these same
techniques in soccer when when you kick
underneath or to the side or slightly
over the top correct that spin that's
right
the magnus effect which correct that's
what that's it's been so named and so
um so if you spin it
backwards
the ball
will not descend
as fast as gravity would otherwise take
it
it still descends
but just not as fast
okay so you're there saying okay it's a
regular fastball
i know how much it's going to drop
between the bat the pitcher's arm and
when it comes so i'm going to swing
where i know it will be
and that that spin that the pitcher put
on it
kept the ball higher than it otherwise
would and generally you swing under the
ball or you'll pop it up
and so
so if you look at the arc of the ball
side to side
you will see the ball sinks it does sink
just not as much as the batter thinks it
will
and so there's a conversation we had
with
ron darling the former mets pitcher yes
who's a tv commentator and he was
explaining to us how he would set
certain hitters up
for certain pitches later on in the game
or later on in the season like he would
throw some junk at them so as he thought
that they thought that that was going to
be the case and i think if you're going
to throw this rising fast ball you have
to set that hitter up earlier on in the
game
oh okay so so as you can bring that
deception and disguise so you're messing
with their expectation
messing with their expectations yes
yeah yeah yeah so throw a regular
fastball that's kind of a a crappy
regular fastball so he doesn't want to
swing at it but he sees the ark
and says yeah okay that's your fast i
got this
throw one over the middle and and see
what i'll do with your fastball that's
supposed to be the reason why you step
out of the batter's box all together
when people think why does it take so
long for
a baseball game to unfold yes
you know it's like i got here tuesday
and i miss work
i'm this work i uh you know i'm i'm
still here but
uh the reason why they step out of the
batter's box is because a lot of hitting
is perception
and the idea is to clear your perception
of the last pitch and
hopefully any other pitches that you
might have in mind and you walk out of
the body's batter's box and you're
supposed to take your gaze away from the
mound and now you're fresh brown you're
fresh and all this stuff actually has a
purpose it's not like superstition
it looks like these guys are being
superstitious because a lot of times
they'll add their own little uh you know
rituals and rituals to it yeah but but
chuck growing up game long games lasted
two hours and many games lasted an hour
40. and now short games last two hours
and they all last three hours so i think
advertisers i was gonna say you
we need more commercial time commercial
time
good so
so so what you might do is mix up a
rising fastball with a sinking fastball
right so now now that you think you got
my rising fastball figured out i now
throw a fastball that's spinning the
other direction and now the force on it
pushes it down rather than up
and then you see you've seen this
because the center field camera picks it
up the ball comes looks like it's coming
straight at the batter and the bottom
drops out of it and the catcher
practically catches it on the ground and
the batter just swings over it and
they've got it so the point is in a
rising fastball nothing rises it simply
doesn't fall as fast as your
as your psychology and your
understanding of gravity would otherwise
have you believe haha
which which in a way makes a which in a
way makes a curveball maybe a little
easier because you're not it's it's not
moving against gravity it's just moving
left to right or it's it's got some arc
that maybe started sort of follow the
arc
you know but with all the all good
pitches are hard to hit so
i don't want to jump in there and say i
could do any better than the dude that
just struck out well you know some
pitchers do the same thing though with
an off speed pitch
so it's like you just it's the same
exact pitch you just don't throw it as
hard you you throw it at chuck speed
like truck speed chuck speed a truck
speed pitch
it's called the chuck speed pitch you
know what i mean first you blaze them
with a 91 mile an hour blaze them again
and then the second one it's like
and they're like us what the hell just
happened
all right so
so i i
so
uh but you should know that the faster
you spin it
the bigger is the magnus effect
okay
so because the difference in the
relative speeds of the air moving across
the ball surface becomes greater and
greater and so
uh the some of the best pictures when
they say boy they got a lot of movement
on that ball yeah it's because of how
quickly they actually spin the ball as
it releases from their from their hand
but this is isn't that when the hitters
reach the the stitching
and they read the rope the speed of
rotation because they can tell from the
the stitching whether it's blurred
whether there's certain things coming
what kind of pitch and they've learned
to read the stitching yeah if you're
good
oh my god i only saw six stitches go by
whoa
so in the tenth of a second i two tenths
of a second i have to decide i would say
oh there's three stitches not four it's
it's coming from left to right and it's
dropping by three centimeters i'm going
to swing here right right
so so anyhow i just wanted to sort of
reinforce
the value of a spinning ball no matter
whether it's a fastball or any other
kind of pitch
if it's spinning
the pressure differences will move it
in ways that give the pitcher amazing
control and and deceptive power over the
batter
lastly
how about the knuckle ball
ooh
so the knuckleball
does not spin
okay
now when you see that ball coming you
can see you can see that
that there's no it's not spinning all
right you just see now the problem there
is and we'll have to save this for
another uh segment at on another show
but
if the ball is not spinning it is not
stabilized as it moves through the air
yes and this is so what i'm going to do
you're unstable no not emotionally
unstable
how many times can this happen
you throw me he throws me back i can't
take it anymore
i can't check
the ball
experiences no emotions right oh okay
sad poker
stability so yeah rotational stability
rotational stability so as it moves
towards you it's not rotationally stable
against the air it's moving through and
so a slight breeze will just carry the
ball to a different place
and so for a knuckleball
especially the catcher they don't know
where the ball is going to end up
and a knuckleball is useless on a on a
day where there's no breeze okay then
it'll just go in a straight arc but if
there's
yeah if it's kind of breezy inside the
stadium and and sometimes it cooks
around you can look at the flags but
that doesn't tell you because those are
up above the the level right of the top
of the stadium so this circulating air
um can be the knuckleballer's best
friend and many knuckleballers are
famous for throwing wild pitches or
having passed balls because the batter
doesn't know where the i mean the the
catcher doesn't know where to put the
mitt as the as the ball moves so that is
the absence of a spin also creating
movement because we don't have a spin
stabilized situation and that's a whole
other segment that we're going to do
guys that's all we have time for but i'm
loving the fact
that our explainer videos are now
spilling into
the sports edition format
i'm loving it
because there's a lot of explaining that
needs to happen in sports too
you ain't lying
okay starting with this off seas it
never mind never mind
[Laughter]
all right chuck gary neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist keep
[Music]